bonsoir didier combo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france médias
américains ont annoncé la victoire de
joe biden est-ce que c'est aux médias
d'annoncer cette victoire a expliqué
nous comment ça fonctionne aux états
unis mais écoutez le
traditionnellement ce sont effectivement
les médias qui annoncent la victoire de
l'un ou de l'autre
sur la base de sondages sortie des urnes
et des urnes et sur la base des premiers
décomptes des voix
et puis ce qui se passe habituellement
c'est que le perdant reconnaît sa
défaite et c'est un petit peu ce qui
intronise le gagnant ce qui ne se
produit pas de cette année les résultats
officiels eux il faudra attendre le 8
décembre pour les avoir lorsque les les
collèges électoraux parce que savez que
c'est une élection indirecte et que les
les
les états vont nommer des grands
électeurs qui vont voter pour trump pour
byden donc laissé collèges électoraux
ils seront sélectionnés le 8 décembre
par les différents états il
ils voteront ces grands électeurs le 14
décembre et il le vote sera dépouillé
par le congrès fédéral le 6 janvier donc
l' annonce officielle au bout du compte
c'est même le 6 janvier 1 et donc on est
dans une situation très très
particulière cette année parce que
d'habitude l'écart est suffisant pour
que la presse puisse dire sans se
tromper qu'il gagne en le soir même de
l'élection et que en général celui qui a
perdu admis sa défaite et annonce
officielle intervient alors il ya une
bataille judiciaire de deux mois qui
s'annonce a priori puisque les partisans
de donald trump ne reconnaissent pas les
résultats vous voyez là la réaction de
rudolph giuliani l'avocat de donald
trump
juste après l'annonce
la victoire de joe biden par cnn pour
lui la fraude est massive écoutez le et
et on en parle après c'est scandaleux
pour un enjeu aussi énorme
avec cette méthode de vote aussi
suspecte il n'y a aucune certitude 0 les
gens de cette ville les gens de ce pays
n'ont aucune assurance que ces votes ont
vraiment été enregistré ils ont presque
exclusivement été compté par des gens
qui souhaitaient que joe biden rattrape
son retard je vous parle de ce qui se
passe à philadelphie mais nous devons
alerter les gens de pittsburgh que la
même fraude qu'ici a été commise et
aussi la même chose s'est passé en
géorgie la même chose a été faite au
michigan
la même chose a été faite en caroline du
nord à moi il me semble que quelqu'un du
comité national démocrate a dû envoyer
une petite note disant ne laissez pas
les républicains regarder de plus près
ces millions de votes dans leurs propos
meriane barotte un didier combo donc une
bataille judiciaire qui s'annnonce elle
devrait durer deux mois c'est court pour
contester oui mais je ne crois pas que
le que la campagne de trump ou que
rudolph giuliani pense que cette
contestation pourrait aboutir à une
victoire de donald trump
je crois qu'il s'agit essentiellement
d'affichage pour bien comprendre cette
situation il faut savoir qu'aux états
unis les taux d'abstention sont très
élevés aux élections et que l'enjeu
finalement ça n'est pas tellement de
convaincre les électeurs de voter pour
soi c'est de compenser ces c'est
d'amener ceux qui sont déjà convaincus
vers les isoloirs et les gens qui
s'abstiennent le plus sont ceux qui
votent habituellement démocrate ce sont
les afro américains ce sont les jeunes
et donc les
il cette question des élections fait
débat entre les républicains et les
démocrates depuis longtemps déjà les
démocrates accusent les républicains de
faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour ne pas
faciliter l'accès aux urnes parce que ce
sont les gens qui iront voter plus
facilement votre ont plutôt démocrates
et les républicains al'inverse accusent
les démocrates de faciliter l'accès aux
urnes
quitte à ne pas suffisamment vérifier si
les gens qui votent sont éligibles
seront le droit de voter et c'est par
exemple la campagne de trump a dit qu'
on avait fait voter des morts et que les
gens avaient voté dans un des gens
avaient voté dans un autre état que le
leur c'est même le fondateur c'est pas
forcément l'équipe de tram c'est le new
york post qui a dit que effectivement
des morts avait peut-être voter repris
évidemment par le camp républicain
que pensez-vous de du style joe biden on
va regarder d'abord son son portrait si
vous le voulez bien à à 77 ans il
deviendrait donc le 46e président des
états unis plus vieux président
américain ténors du parti démocrate et
fidèle bras droit de barack obama son
portrait signé solène gaudin et on en
parle après à 77 ans joe biden est un
homme politique chevronné sénateur
démocrate pendant 37 ans il maîtrise les
arcanes du congrès une expérience qui a
attiré l'attention de barack obama
pendant ces huit années de mandat à la
tête des états unis ce dernier lui
confie la vice présidence avant de
l'adouber comme candidat à la
présidentielle de 2008
mais il aura fallu 3 convention
démocrate pour voir l'ancien colistier
de barack obama s'est lancé dans la
course à la maison blanche face à donald
trump un grand honneur et une grande
humilité
j'accepte cette investiture pour la
présidence des états unis d'amérique
à plusieurs reprises sa vie privée a
fait obstacle à sa vie politique
en 1972 il perd sa première épouse et sa
fille dans un accident de voiture
il a seulement 30 ans et entame son
premier mandat de sénateur puis en 2015
son fils beau meurt d'un cancer ce deuil
le pousse à renoncer à l'investiture
démocrate 2020 année de la consécration
dans la continuité des candidats
démocrates précédent il s'engage dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
contre les armes à feu et les
discriminations raciales et en faveur
d'une meilleure couverture santé alors
que les violences policières le
blacklight matters et la pandémie de
profit de 19 se sont invités en pleine
campagne électorale
joe biden se voit en rassembleur et
protecteur une image qui tu veux tu en
opposition à celle de son adversaire
mes amis la première responsabilité d'un
président et de protéger le peuple
américain mais il ne le fait pas cela le
disqualifie totalement croix récemment
des accusations sont venues ternir son
image geste déplacé envers des
collaboratrices est affaire de
corruption internationale par
l'intermédiaire de son fils enter des
accusations démenties sans effet de
manche
hayden se repose sur une réputation
bâtie de longue haleine mais en
pennsylvanie dans une famille catholique
mode est proche des milieux ouvriers
il a gravi les échelons politiques 1 à 1
celui qui fut élu plus jeune sénateur
démocrate en 1972 franchi aujourd'hui la
plus haute marche de sa carrière en
devenant président des états unis
didier combo un joe biden à 77 ans s'il
est confirmé il sera donc le 46e
président d des états unis
comment va-t-il pouvoir
gouverner s'il est confirmé évidemment
dans une amérique profondément divisé on
l'a vu c'est tout l'enjeu
d'autant plus que cette victoire est
loin d'être écrasante on a vu qu'il a il
a fallu plusieurs jours on arrivait à
départager les deux candidats
les le sénat est encore en suspens il ya
des chances qu'il demeure républicain
mais il y aura d un deuxième tour pour
un certain nombre de sénateurs en début
janvier le et les démocrates ont perdu
quelques sièges à la chambre donc c'est
loin d'être une victoire écrasante
les partisans de tromper les
républicains ou quand même engrangé de
très bons résultats par rapport au
handicap qu'ils avaient avec l'aco vide
avec le le vote par correspondance qui
qui qui fit plus aux démocrates donc ça
va être un enjeu et les chantiers qui
sont eux qui sont devant le devant le
nouveau président ne sont pas minces la
question de la réforme de la police la
question des relations raciales de la
réforme des six pénale la question bien
évidemment du coc vide de la justin du
plan de soutien à l'économie donc c'est
vraiment une situation extrêmement
difficile à laquelle le président bailly
donné la vice-présidente kamala harris
deux compères passent kamala harris
effectivement puisque pour la première
fois dans l'histoire des usa 6 s'il est
confirmé président en janvier il y aura
une femme vice-présidente
c'est donc kamala harris qui a 56 ans
sera aussi la première femme noire à
être élue vice-présidente et ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'elle est
pionnière puisqu'elle a aussi été la
première procureur noir de californie
avant d'être choisie par john pye donne
didier combo kamala harris c'est les
jeunes
elle est noire allait plutôt populaire
chez les démocrates joe biden huile à 77
ans ce serait sa carte sim ou s'il
venait à ce qu'il ne soit plus en mesure
de gouverner
oui oui bien sûr c'est si le président
depuis en mesure de gouverner c'est la
vice-présidente qui devient
automatiquement présidente
et puis joe biden a dit qu'il ne ferait
qu'un mandat étant donné son âge et donc
kabala harris sera probablement la
candidate naturelle du parti démocrate
pour l'élection de 2024 éventuellement
et je crois que c'est certainement ça là
la vraie nouveauté de la deux le le vrai
fait historique de cette élection c'est
l'élection du 10 présidente de couleurs
qui n'est pas vérifiée un qui n'est pas
tout à fait afro américaine puisque 100
avec les jamaïcains sa méridienne
mais c'est une femme de couleur qui qui
qui accède à la vice présidente à la
fois une femme est à la fois de leurs
soins la chrono le choix justement de
kamala harris comme vice-président que
ça a joué aussi en faveur de joe biden
selon vous oui je pense que le le couple
byden kamala harris était certainement
le meilleur ticket qui pouvaient exister
pour que le parti démocrate des se
trouver puisque finalement joe biden
donald trump c'étaient des hommes à peu
près du même âge blanc l'un et l'autre
de 30 n'avait pas beaucoup de dak roche
pour critiquer pour critiquer baden
beaucoup moins en tout cas que pour
critiquer pour que pour s'en prendre à
hillary clinton en 2016 il puis cela a
été contrebalancé par le fait qu' on
avait une femme est une femme de couleur
comme com
[Musique]
joe biden qui est entouré de femmes
puisque à la tête de la chambre des
représentants il ya une démocrate nancy
pelosi
c'est un atout également pour ce mandat
a priori de joe biden oui c'est un atout
c'est aussi quelque chose qui peut qui
peut cadrer un petit peu les
masculinisme de les masculinistes du
côté de du côté des électeurs de trump
puisqu'on a vu ses milices blanche comme
par exemple les play boys qui sont eux
qui sont exclusivement masculin et donc
il va falloir composer composer avec ça
et faire que le ce qui avait donné la
victoire à donald trump en 2016 les
hommes blancs plus diplômés ne se
sentent pas suffisamment on ne se sent
pas complètement mis de côté par cette
nouvelle orientation de la société
américaine de location pour pas vraiment
nouvelle qui date des années 60 mais
faire que il n'est pas une réaction aux
violences contre voilà c'est la grande
question cette amérique divisé peut-être
basculé dans la violence c'est ce qui
nous fait une crise de confiance dans le
système électoral américain aujourd'hui
oui il ya visiblement une crise de
confiance dans le système électoral et
ça c'est aussi un des grands problèmes
de des états unis c'est que les
américains n'ont plus confiance dans
leur propre élection est donc par
exemple la preuve a répété que
l'élection lui a été volé et et lorsque
trump a été élu en 2016 c'était les
démocrates qui hurlait que trump avait
volé l'élection parce qu'il n'avait pas
tenu du fait du collège électoral il
n'avait pas obtenu une majorité des
suffrages populaires donc rien il y a un
problème avec le système électoral
américain et c'est très ennuyeux dans
une démocratie parce que le système
d'élection c'est quand même ce qui est
au coeur de la démocratie
on va parler d'eux
de la diplomatie selon joe biden va
d'abord regarder ses dirigeants
étrangers qui ont déjà félicité joe
biden alors que je le rappelle le
dépouillement est toujours en cours dans
certains états regarder les américains
ont désigné leur président félicitations
joe biden et kamala harris
nous avons beaucoup à faire pour relever
les défis d'aujourd'hui
agissons ensemble c'est bien qu'il y ait
enfin des chiffres clairs nous sommes
impatients de travailler avec le
prochain gouvernement américain nous
voulons investir dans notre coopération
pour un nouveau départ dans la relation
transatlantique
un new deal toutes nos félicitations joe
biden et kamala harris nos deux pays
sont des amis proches des partenaires et
des alliés nous partageons une relation
unique sur la scène mondiale
j'ai vraiment hâte de travailler
ensemble et de développer cela avec vous
deux je félicite chaleureusement joe
biden et kamala harris pour leur
victoire aux élections présidentielles
américaines
l'ue et les états unis sont des amis et
des alliés nos citoyens partagent les
liens les plus profonds j'ai hâte de
travailler avec le président élu byden
félicitations à joe biden pour son
élection en tant que président des états
unis et à kamala harris pour leur
réussite historique
les etats unis sont notre allié le plus
important et j'ai hâte de coopérer
étroitement sur nos priorités communes
du changement climatique au commerce
ainsi que sur la défense
je félicite joe biden pour son élection
en tant que prochain président américain
et kamala harris en tant que vice
présidente je connais joe biden en tant
que fervent partisan de notre alliance
et j'ai hâte de travailler en étroite
collaboration avec lui un au temps fort
est bon pour l'amérique du nord et
l'europe ont voilà donc pour les
réactions internationales elles sont
elles sont surtout européennes didier
combos à commencer par emmanuel macron
l'allemagne également qui avait été
plutôt malmené par donald trump
qu'est-ce que ça va changer selon vous
alors oui les les il est dans l'habitude
que le que que les dirigeants de divers
pays fait six lits félicite le
le vainqueur et donald trump était très
18,6 de la sioniste il est sorti d'un
certain nombre d'accords il est sorti du
du de l'accord de paris il est sorti du
traité qui avaient été obtenus avec les
avec les iraniens il est sorti du lot
oms pour le lait traité de désarmement
il participait plus vraiment non plus
donc on peut s'attendre à ce que les
états unis reviennent dans ces accords
bilatéraux et reviennent dans le
bilatéralisme cela dit il faut pas
oublier que en termes de relations
internationales ça a toujours été la
règle c'est que chaque pays prend en
compte en premier lieu ses propres
intérêts donc il va y avoir très
certainement un changement de style au
niveau des relations internationales le
changement de fond sera peut-être moins
drastiques
on peut l'imaginer ce qui concerne
l'europe et l'otan on a on a vu jens
stoltenberg réagir et féliciter jo by
dane le l'otan
donald trump avait plutôt tendance à
vouloir délaisser cette organisation
également et inciter ses partenaires
européens à participer davantage
ça va relancer un peu c'est ce
partenariat avec l'europe et avec l'otan
oui c'est pas c'est pas impossible mais
néanmoins le beaucoup d'américains ne
comprennent pas très bien pourquoi les
américains devraient payer pour la
défense de l'europe et on évitera
certainement avec avec eux un
gouvernement bat et donne une trop
grande de guerre commerciale entre
l'europe et des états unis
mais encore une fois les etats-unis
feront très certainement passer leurs
propres intérêts avant les intérêts de
leurs partenaires mais sauront tout même
des relations plus cordiales avec avec
leurs parts changement de style dans les
paroles on va écouter une dernière
réaction si vous le voulez bien c'est
celle de barack obama qui a on s'en
souvient beaucoup soutenu joe biden
pendant la campagne
lors de cette élection et dans des
circonstances il est dit les américains
se sont révélés comme jamais une fois
tous les votes pris en compte le
président élu joe biden et la vice
présidente élue kamala harris ont
remporté une victoire décisive et
historique à didier combo est ce que
barack obama n'a pas
était un peu l'élément clé on l'a vu
beaucoup ces derniers temps pour
soutenir justement joe biden qui
hésitaient à aller sur les meetings à
cause du virus
oui barack obama s'est beaucoup investi
ce qui n'est pas très fréquent chez les
des anciens présidents américains qui
habituellement prennent une certaine
distance vis-à-vis de la de la vie
politique du pays s'investisse plus
souvent dans des actions humanitaires
par exemple est hélas barack obama a
senti la nécessité de soutenir joe biden
et ce soutien très certainement été le
bienvenu en particulier auprès des
communautés afroaméricaine naturellement
dont on sait qu'ils votent
majoritairement démocrate mais cela a
permis de les mobiliser pour qu'ils
aillent voter justement on va on va
parler de donald trump à présent il
reste de moins pour terminer son mandat
il devra quitter la maison blanche en
janvier
peu la situation peut-elle
se retourne et est-ce que selon vous les
résultats peuvent être juridiquement
contestait ce qui vient au précédent
dans l'histoire des états unis
oui c'est s'est déjà produit que les
résultats soient contestés par exemple
joe biden a demandé un recompte des
voeux par nom de donald trump a demandé
un recompte des voix dans le wisconsin
c'est arrivé assez fréquemment c'est
arrivé en il y a quelques années et ce
recomptage avait fait changer 1500 voix
sur l'ensemble des bois du wisconsin
donc il est très peu probable que c'est
que ces recours aboutissent même si ça
peu un petit peu changé les résultats
mais de manière trop marginal pour que
le pour que l'élection soit contesté
d'ailleurs vous avez vu que la presse a
mis plusieurs jours à confirmer ces
résultats
et si la presse les a confirmées c'est
que vraiment il n'ya il n'y a plus aucun
doute sur sur ses résultats
merci beaucoup didier combo d'avoir un
décrypter ces résultats avec nous en
direct sur rtl france merci